yes yes
these films changed how we interpreted
samurai or katana sword fighting wow
that's such a great stunt
okay but no seriously how do you do that
without breaking your ribs i think you
just break your ribs
thanks to rikoff for sponsoring this
episode stick around to see how you can
save 15 off of your first order
hey everybody welcome back to another
episode of stuntmen react we're here
with our good friend and good stunt man
gee
what's up
yo thanks for having me back if you guys
have been watching the show you remember
gee he's had incredible insights into a
bunch of amazing stunts as well as being
an incredible stunt performer himself
with some amazing credits to his name
got my coffee
all right yeah yeah all right let's do
it yeah let's
do it
yes dude this guy that hair john claude
van damme in his prime
business in the front
party in the back
yes
oh my god
watch your legs
somebody really did that geez flawless
wow
lands it on his feet too
really loads
it blows it up
no that's the matrix reloaded yeah yeah
that's the same thing it's the same
thing
this leap over the car it's so clean
it's so clean it's almost too clean you
can see the stun guy kind of like
realized that she's landing so this is
too perfect i'm gonna let them i gotta
make this a little bit messy dude this
is what really sticks with me about all
these stunts and all these films is that
when they show somebody doing it for
real there's a part of me inside that
goes a hero could do that yes if there's
a guy in this moment who needed to do
this moment he could actually do it
theoretically this is a possible move
for a guy to do against bad guys that's
such a great stunt and it's shot and
edited so well it's like jumping the
line and all weird but it works so well
it does this stunt man justice which is
really great to see it gives you a good
reaction going yeah
like come on dude the mullet just shot a
car and blew it up the pistol cut to a
shot of the dude going yeah got to yeah
i want movies like this again incredible
hell yeah john woo thank you
is this some live action anime we're
about to this is some live action anime
we are about to watch this is kenshin
versus sojiro in roroni kenshin kyoto
inferno amy johnson pulled a clip for us
from this one yeah from a different
fight scene i
brought this clip to you guys because i
really enjoy this adaptation of the
anime these films changed how we
interpreted samurai or katana sword
fighting it set a new trend because now
everybody wants to perform in this kind
of tempo rhythm and movement and this
was like a pure example of that
nice it's quick and they don't cut it's
very lightsabery
[Music]
the actors are doing this dude and the
punch the ground you have to get up
dude that's awesome fight scenes for me
when they do stuff like that that i
don't see before that's what i'm always
looking for right that's what makes it
special for me definitely feel like
they're using larp swords for the
fighting yes that allows them to make
full contact and for it to not have that
weird wobble where it's also safe for
the actors to use because clearly when
we watch this you're seeing these long
takes it's the actor which is really fun
to watch that's why a lot of us enjoy a
lot of these action films like john wick
we see keanu actually do the action it
also allows the editor to not have to
cut around so ghee you know they're the
actual actors doing this choreo they
clearly have some prop weapons that are
light and easy to handle how hard is it
to do this choreography at the pace that
they're doing it and at the rhythms i
would say they definitely had to
rehearse for a good two to three weeks
it's definitely not some cookie cutter
choreography there's break beats in
there the double tap that's not
something we're used to doing or seeing
so therefore i think that because of the
rhythms it made it even more of a
challenge for them to learn it which
gives them even more props for taking
the time to actually show up and do it
well i think the other huge strength
that just showcased here is how much
storytelling is happening in the
fighting there's constant mini problems
happening and problem solving happening
that's the core of a good fight scene
and they're constantly doing it with
their physicality where problem the guy
is down the ground solution he can run
on the ground right problem he needs to
dodge solution punch the ground do a
flip they're constantly coming up with
little mini beats of a story where it's
a guy's in a disadvantage situation and
just something clever that you haven't
seen before to get into the advantage
that moment of what's that something
clever to get you into that advantage
that you haven't seen before that's the
hardest part about all this and they're
doing it you know with every fight scene
here the biggest thing about fight scene
is at the end of it what have we learned
about the character and what has changed
to our character like here we see that
they're even neither of them have gotten
a hit on each other which then leads
them to be like okay let's go with
another tactic let's see who's better at
uncheating that's what's really cool
about it is it's constantly a tit in and
it just builds up their relationship for
when they fight again in the future
if you guys are enjoying this content
and are not subscribed then consider
subscribing because we love bringing all
the fun videos to you guys and we got a
lot more planned
[Music]
this is a film that i got to work on i
did the third act and i was doubling
jamie foxx who's like one of my
childhood heroes i got to work with him
and do this fight scene and it was
probably like one of the coolest moments
that was a fun fall doing that that was
you yeah the flip yeah okay boom
yeah i can see your face really clearly
[Music]
looks like jamie's doing a lot of the
choreo here yeah and that's what's
really cool about it of course i love
doing this stuff as well but he showed
up to rehearsals he was there every time
we went to rehearse every time we had a
second tv like let's run the
choreography and me and him would stand
there and we'd do the choreography
together and he's very good at taking
what i did and imitating it to the best
of his ability and then we run it over
and over again and next thing no he
looks just like me and it's like well he
got it to the point where it they don't
need me to do it as much it was a fun
opportunity and fun time to get to meet
jamie and see how he works and i learned
so much from it because there's more to
being the lead guy on a film outside of
being in front of the camera is what you
do off the camera being on the set
especially when it comes to night shoots
everybody's there it's late it's cold
things can be at times a little grueling
and hard as the lead you kind of are the
person that everybody looks to and if
the lead is energy is up and he's having
fun and he's reminding everybody that
you're having fun it keeps you in that
state of oh yeah we're making a movie
we're having a good time we're still
enjoying this it's not a job and that's
what he does and that's a big thing in
my opinion when it comes to what you do
off camera
so this is another film that i want to
bring to you guys the odd couple and
this is samuel hung this is probably one
of the best hong kong weapon movies ever
done
[Music]
so like dancy this is marshall club city
right here oh yeah this is this is
absolutely marshall club this is where
they get all their inspiration
[Music]
this move right here what
[Applause]
the camera work is amazing other things
that stand out to me is like the white
cuffs on the sleeves so you can follow
the arm yep that's actually really smart
it's like the chinese opera right and
that's samuel's training that's where he
came from that's where jackie came from
that's how he met jackie that's how you
met yin biao they all were part of the
same school and it was coming to the end
of opera samuel's like the new thing is
movies and he started working as a stunt
guy and pulled them in stunt guys they
became a director he became an actor if
jackie and samo and all these guys
weren't forced as children to join this
opera school we wouldn't have them we
wouldn't have any of these great movies
guys in this particular style of wushu
it's very much performance-based because
these guys are opera trained but they
also learn the combative forms and if
you give somebody who's trained in this
and give them a spear i'm sure they tear
you up they tear me up go watch the odd
couple it's a really fun film
[Music]
so this is knock about directed by
samuel hung starring yam yao and this is
the final fight
[Music]
it's so acrobatic i love it yep
dude
[Laughter]
this is like donkey and diddy
just monkeying out
yes
[Music]
yes oh my god wow
that hurts so bad this is very wwe you
got the barbed wire fight you got the
people's elbows
jump rope competition started from this
i like the occasional kicks
oh my god
and then he does this move
yeah man that is awesome that's the worm
it is the worm
you're right
do it do it samo
shut up oh my god wait that's a lighter
guy yeah it's not [ __ ] still
dude he gets so much air okay but no
seriously how do you do that without
breaking your ribs i think you just
break your ribs are you kidding me it
looks like they're putting a pad on his
stomach so
but yeah no that's painful dude
have you ever heard of anyone gearing up
to do a stunt knowing that they're
definitely gonna break something no
matter what yeah you guys remember the
run down when they go down the hill oh
yeah and they have to hit everything on
the way down
[Music]
the story is that they're standing up
there and they're sitting there and
they're looking he's uncoordinated and
he's like i'll see you guys down there
he jumps what so the coordinator jumps
down oh my god and it takes
that does it all and so now you see the
coordinator do it and you're like wait
he just did it
they're like the only way down is to do
that so they just jump and they go
[Music]
wow oh damn wow damn
scrambled dude they gotta get up and do
it again but
there's some really hard hits yeah right
legitimate hits and they didn't cut away
thankfully that definitely was painful
it looks very difficult
i want to talk about today's sponsor
raycon from start to finish raycon
prioritizes the user experience by
designing premium wireless audio for you
know half the price without any
compromise what's cool about these is
that raycon offers a bunch of different
colors and patterns in their earbuds
raycon earbuds give you six hours of
playtime and they have seamless
bluetooth pairing they've got more bass
and a more compact design for a
comfortable noise isolating fit i wear
raycons when i go out onewheeling
because they block out the noise of the
wind because they have an isolating fit
blocking out all exterior sounds like
this i can't hear you now i can't hear
you
this does the same thing as raycons and
of course the best thing is that there
are no dangling wires or stems they just
stick in your ear and you don't even
know they're there all you got to do is
click the link in the description or
just go to byracon.com corridor crew and
you'll get 15 off your order and if you
do want to return them well guess what
raycon has a 45 day free return policy
once again that is
byracon.com corridor crew and you will
get 15 off your order gee thank you so
much for joining us i learned so much i
hope you guys learned a thing or two and
if you want to learn more go check out
gee on instagram at yi x the silva give
him some love did you have a lot of fun
leave a comment let us know what you
guys think and i'll be back if you don't
subscribe i'm not coming back it'll be
very sad for me because i don't get to
spend time with my friends and you don't
want to see me sad actually it'd be
really really sad for me too because
i couldn't be even smash bros